uh good morning um good afternoon
actually um from new york city this is
dr lana morrow calling
and um i
will be
delivering a talk on neuroeconomy
and how it impacts
neurodegenerative disorders
magnitude of cost internationally
nationally
i have been um giving some talks on um
neuroeconomy now for uh more than a year
um i think um
working with neurodegenerative diseases
and with
speaking with moses chao and a few other
people who are interested in economic
impact uh on and loss of productivity um
due to
neurological or neurodegenerative
diseases
um
we
all understand and agree that
the losses
of staggering proportion and
we have
as individuals
previously i think people have not paid
attention to the magnitude of um
the impact of productivity loss and
economic burden that neurodegenerative
diseases pose on
everyday life
and economy global and national um my
name is dr lana morrow i'm
a neurotechnologically
um
geared neuroscientist um i have
a few inventions behind
in my history um practically i
try to
invent new devices that
enable people to transmit the thought to
the software and
computers
ipads uh pdas and um therefore um enable
faster and less economically burdened
research um globally and and nationally
and we work with
several institutions uh abroad and um
here in new york city
um mainly i interact with some people
from columbia university um where i was
trained with jakob stern
and we
interact with uh we actually do a lot of
research with uh saint paul hospital in
barcelona
as well with um we have some research
planned now with petey salvatiere in
paris um both in the the main frontal
lobe functioning um and cognition
working memory
sustained attention
overall cognitive reserve
and
you know
we
are right now working on research in
adhd
potential capacities sustained attention
and we are planning several
studies on parkinson
and
healthy aging
today i would like to speak about the
neural economy in the field of neural
economies very young
um we need to raise awareness of the
impact of
the neurodegenerative diseases on
economy and people usually are not aware
of
how
meaningful
neurotech and
various
you know
new technology could actually be
for um
neuro economical impact in the world and
on
everyday lives
you may wonder how does the um
neurotechnological systems uh how does
angular technological system um impact
the neural economy um it is not very
obvious at the first sight um and i'm
going to try to explain uh my best
ability um
if um
if you have a
neurocycle neurotech device that works
and is enabling you to reach as a
medical professional professional is
enabling you to reach
thousands of people at once
without
them having to travel to you or you have
a
significantly reliable
uh research-proven uh data
world bank and
uh capacity through neural technological
devices to actually access your patient
and enable this route between
communication between
the patient and the provider
and you plug that into the
insurance cost as well
we are able to prove that the costs of
economical burden
is definitely much less
um
the diminishing of the cost benefits not
only the provider or the insurance
agents but it benefits
first and foremost the
patient
or the subject and
they can be healthy patients healthy
individuals who just want information
they can be
researchers who would like to join hands
internationally and access multiple
thousands of patients at the same time
and access reliable data and we all know
that reliable data
monitored by computers can give you more
specific values namely it can you know
just a panel example of rehabilitation
if you rehabilitate a patient
after a sports injury or after a spinal
cord injury
you can monitor their data in hospital
and all is well while you have a
reliable
doctor or technician who is in the
hospital and who monitors the patient's
progress again this is not very
scientific um still it's not comparable
to the data on fmri or
um battle that is that are you know
derived from let's say
um a gate platform but um
still um you know it's more reliable
than when the patient goes home and uh
which reports to you that um he has done
you know his follow your chart and has
uh performed several exercises you
really don't know the researchers really
don't have any ways of knowing exactly
how many exercises person really perform
to what quality level to what repetition
level in what positioning of the body um
people have to simply trust each other
now if um there is a exact and precise
highly defined and highly reliable
technical or neurotechnical gadget or
device in place
in order to perform those uh exercises
the
patient even at home has to adhere to a
certain standard of the protocol and the
data is logged into the
network uh into a system where um
provider then can reliably actually
access the data and
get the data evaluated down to a
millisecond and with precision of a
millimeter which is then
quite valuable for research um
dr thomas insult
um
value has spoken he's in the national
institute of mental health director um
he speaks on estimates of global
economic burden and standard cost of
illness methods macroeconomics
simulation um value of statistical life
there are different economical
approaches to
valuing economic
burden
over you know values decades uh of
course this is a framework primal and
crucial importance in
governmental you know institutions
because um
we
tend to not really thinking immediately
about indirect costs and cumulative
output laws of and burden
in the world
or in the united states
in order to progress and be able to
really access multiple millions of
patients and
subjects
people
persons we need to be able to
effectively cut the costs
and all while having reliable
capacitors and
reliable measures of gathering the data
such as reliable devices lab or
technological
systems and software programs that are
actually
statistically validified and tested and
not just presented as
programs that have been invented by some
you know
some
digital programmer and not
validated and not tested um just like um
solid scientific studies these uh data
gathering systems and devices as well as
software programs and
capacitors have to be tested and run
through rigorous scientific studies so
that we know precisely that they are not
reporting some
random data but there is a there is a
mathematical statistical and medical
validity that is replicable and
validated through institutions that we
trust um and as such i think so far i
don't personally know of any um systems
that really happen
on the digital side have been actually
medically and technically validated to
the level that uh we can say the
rigorous studies conducted and we
actually can trust this data
um and that's i think one of the very
important
standards industry standards that we
have to impose when we talk about
helping the economy and medical
community uh achieve better levels of um
savings and better levels of efficacy of
reaching you know multiple um
multiple
goals of
not only providers but also
patients
world health organization um data show
that mental illnesses are the leading
causes of disability um
in down in suggested life years
worldwide
we i was when i read the numbers i was
extremely surprised um
37 of healthy years lost um derived from
income laws um
due to
mental health differences uh they affect
uh directly and indirectly not only the
the person who is suffering from mental
health illness but also
the
companies they work with
families the their caretakers their
family members um depression for example
accounts for one-third of this
disability estimates of the global cost
of mental illnesses are at nearly 2.5
trillion dollars that staggering number
and just in 2010
so these are somewhat older data but
very reliable
the entire global health spending in
2009 was 5.1 trillion dollars and that
compared to annual
gdp for low income countries is less
than one trillion so
that's five times more than annual um
uh gdp that's the numbers are tremendous
um and i think that's
probably for governments that's one of
the important um ways of possibly saving
trillions of dollars and
all while saving money to the government
saving money to the taxpayers saving
money to the
people who are affected who could
possibly then
have to pay much less in
insurance costs and have effectively
much more
direct contact with their own doctor
whether they're in england or italy
whether they're you know um
on warfronts in
in
africa
um
we could actually enable people to
communicate with each other less much
faster to be able to diagnose faster to
pass some of the preliminary exams
screening uh in a very efficient and
reliable way all while also still having
access to their own provider
at the fraction of the cost
if we have a technology that is
validated and standardized to the world
you know standard
then
approved by world health organization or
nmih or nih
um
brain disorders
have
accounted for humongous
humongous
numbers
these are the brain disorders numbers in
europe
so we have um european in europe 790
798 billion uh in 2000 total cost in
europe only observers of the brain and
here numbers by broken by anxiety
74 um
105 um
billion
um are in europe of dementia just in
2010 parkinson's accounts for 13.9
tbi is a big um problem uh it counts for
uh 33 uh billion euros just in 2010
mental retardation you know we all know
that if your your child is born mentally
um she can't or she cannot
really take care of themselves when
they're involved and they're
economically
burdening uh imminently you know their
caretakers their parents and whoever is
assisting them and the society so if we
can prevent any of that or
mediate it to the level that actually we
can
help it remediate on some better levels
more efficiently cutting costs not only
to the families and directly affected
patients but also to the society that
would be
important
the numbers
for um
usa
we have here for
adhd um these are areas i'm personally
interested in and have given numerous
stocks on so i'm familiar with these
numbers um these are the numbers derived
from an mh
um
6.4 million children and 10 million
adults um are um affected by adhd and
their significant disorder meaning they
can't pay attention they have to be on
drugs they have to be um or they have
problems they create a problem in
classroom or in the family especially
when the
problem
of attention is pronounced hyperactivity
can become quite
a difficult um difficult disease to
think and uh or
you know manifestation of disorder to
then manage
um
the numbers um are about um
quite quite high we have about
um um
sources here um of nine billion sales of
stimulant in 2012 so we know that
numbers seem to be uh
overly you know the
stimulants are overly prescribed and
that seems to be a consensus now
um partially because uh there are not
too many rigorous studies conducted and
now we have more and more regular
studies being conducted on adhd and
double blind studies that are really
truly necessary to assess uh what really
um encompasses the attention necessary
problem or issue and how can we address
it in ways that are not just
medical but also behavioral or through
frequency specific training there are
many different strains now in the field
that are being explored and nih and nmh
is
allocating more and more grants now to
help
fund better research
um in alzheimer's disease we have about
5.4 million alzheimer's patients uh in
the usa 36 million globally
um by 2030 um nmh uh
predicts that it'll search 250 million
um
uh alzheimer's patients in the world in
in the usa
um
uh the cost to the society right now is
humongous we're talking about 200
billion billion dollars of annual costs
as a society
and um 70 of that are covered by
medicare and medicaid
um and that's the source you know source
for that was alzheimer's association
2012.
um
in parkinson we have a similar
data
um parkinson's disease foundation in
2013 reports that there is 10 million
people globally affected by uh
parkinson's disease about four percent
of that are ages 16 and above
and um they spend tremendous amount of
money only for medications um
um per patient there is a surgical
interaction now we know that you can you
know
undergo surgical integration this may be
or may not be successful uh the rate of
success is not tremendous of the numbers
are growing daily and we're very
grateful for that um
the numbers are huge again um in um
hundreds thousands of dollars for
surgery per patient
if we can find some more feasible
methods that would be wonderful
um
to to improve and increase uh valuation
in patients with
parkinson
in some over two billion people suffer
from brain based health and productivity
laws which translates into two trillion
dollar economic burden so the red flags
are everywhere and we know that um in
the world people are really um
eagerly trying to
uh malluary the situation
of the economic impact of the um
of the burden of neurodegenerative
diseases in the world um
i'm going to slide 16
um
sorry um
18.
how can we prevent that prevention and
treatment saves the cost so if for
example in schools we're giving
training to children to
whether it is behavioral or um
training through
neurotech technology that now proves to
be um
children's capacity to
focusing children feel um more
successful at school our daca
proved that the children are increasing
their
scores in school by at least one point
they feel happier teachers and parents
report um better
behaviors on brief and commerce
we have various
statistically significant results
on
validated scales and not only in scales
because in hebrew data and fmri data
children become less aggressive as a
result they grow up to be stronger lots
less probability of depression alcohol
drug abuse um similar data not by our
group but other groups showing
post-traumatic stress disorder in adults
soldiers in war um have repeatedly you
know
respond
positively to treatment
that decreases cause of the society nih
now is funding some grants on
post-traumatic stress disorder on mild
traumatic brain injury as well pbi data
very important
and
this is just one
short study
batman and villanova
they have brought
some of their systems to the
um
to
the war zone and measured soldiers with
ptsd and then
we see this is one of the graphs that
they show the concentration and
everything ameliorates in in a very
short amount of time this is about a
month of treatment i think they were
training
training soldiers um
four times a week
and um they performed you know soldiers
performed and reported much better uh
focusing in mutual relaxation capacity
um this was done with um
alkaline
treatment and um
you know training simply
for um
better better focusing and better
relaxation uh mayo clinic uh shows
tremendous results with i don't have a
slide for mayo clinic here but we all
know that they have achieved um
tremendous results with um
lowering the high blood pressure with
just simple breathing devices and
breathing techniques they're they're not
very sophisticated but they work
and at long distance you can actually
measure the data you can plug that
breathing um you know technique even
into the computer
and the provider measures you know
breathing grades and breathing uh and
then the i think pulse rate um the
various various um software programs now
that um mayo clinic is putting a lot of
um emphasis on uh in order to lower the
blood pressure and lower the stress
levels so we we know that stress levels
if we lower stress levels lower the
blood pressure levels we can actually
impact the anxiety levels and we can
there is direct correlation between
anxiety and concentration and we can you
know improve uh people's uh
well-being
also through those techniques again
there are
they can be used in concomitants with
medication they can be used long
distance
but
i cannot emphasize more the fact that we
need to have
better double-blind studies more
validated data and
more validation not only at the level of
data of the study but also validation of
the devices and then the software
programs and those software programs and
techniques have to be treated just like
a medical drug they have to be
undergoing uh medical studies the
regular rigorous double-blind um and
shampoo
and only then we can actually claim
success for those studies and that that
is a field that should be opened um
and um should be um funded as well
um
um we work with with comm university and
collaborate with nyu iki sabritiere
massabienza and sao pao
we do believe that it's really important
to
perform double blind study always that
is shampoo and that is technically
validated um and
we're trying to set up the standards
that we hope
will be followed at the level of um you
know not only at the level of
neurotech
and bcis which right now we don't know
of many that follow those kind of hard
hybrid standards uh in fact because it's
rather difficult to design a study that
is double blind and shampoo
when you have a high-tech
gadget device uh but also people are not
educated when they come to when it comes
to um
the
uh neurotech uh or health neurotech or
health tech
bio technology
software
um they do not think that it's necessary
to perform um double-blind validated
studies
um
and i think it's it's it's imprinted
that those standards being put in place
in order to then globally help people
and get used to the fact that we can
actually
perform um evaluations and and uh
treatment long distance and which would
then cut costs um
i'm going to go to slide
two
so for example in um
in
neural
tech right now we have um this kind of
caps that are being used in the setup so
that means for the patients has to
the patient has to go to the hospital to
clinic
get fired
it takes about an hour of technician's
time it has about an hour or half an
hour at least of the neurologists to
come in and assess all
of uh measuring the data analysis of the
data of course they are plugged into
real um ac dc current um and they have
to stand still that's not very practical
and the cost is is
i think about about eight thousand
dollars per session of about an hour and
a half uh we propose something like this
um we already have numerous studies that
our study shows uh results that are
fantastic
we have about um
a 52 percent increase in
target detection and uh 50 to 54
decrease
in uh omission um of the targets so
showing the fantastic data that are also
revealed and
comparative on fmri
uh that i will show that there is a
significant increase in capacity to
train to to to
focus and sustain focus for long amount
of time after using a treatment with
sustained um
you know a neuro technological device
that is rigorously tested and um can be
operated long distance by a pda like an
ipad or a iphone or um
computer
and plugged into then you know a
database that is in the hospital and
that
any provider can access um
i'm going to go back to the
slide that you know i think it's a
crucial for this
um
talk that we would like to
cut down the
humongous trimming
to trim our economic burden
and based on on the neural behavioral
diseases uh losses and i think that um
that's what we have been talking to
uh you know nih and nih and i think that
that is um significantly important
in order to
to be able to
promote
a level of validation
of
you know
new
neural technologies in the world that
could help um
could help
um not only millions of people around
the globe but could help um our economic
situation and this is just one ideas one
of the ideas that we have and we're
plugging forward with that
um personally we have um
we have an annual award that we give a
lifetime achievement award to
prominent researchers this year
this past year we gave um
um
uh i think award to dr jean christophe
koval
who conducts a large significantly large
studies on parkinson and he is uh
one of the people that we work with and
who promotes um
the idea that neurotechnology is
important and will be the cutting edge
of the next decade um
and uh
we're trying to help
neuro research and um we support the
research um
not for profit arena as well
um and we're
very very um grateful to be able to work
with the world level um neuroscientists
and
at the top level of technology
and uh
and neuroscience and we reach the
disciplines i think that's very very
important to create large
large groups of people who can actually
work together and um
collaborate truly and support each other
um on that note i would like to
conclude the talk and open
the debate for question answers
thank you
you